yeah they won't need you will need a
like a period of time where you kind of
kind of express yourself and you know
whatever it is that's getting you down
to make you feel upset but like what's
more important is the solution so that
you can reach your end goal like because
I I do agree it's kind of like you're
going round and round in circle and
you're not getting any better you're
just going one from point A to B and
then back to a again like you know what
I'm saying so yeah you may need that
time to be like you know this happened
and like kind of let all your feelings
out but there has to be a solution like
so you can progress and move forward